l'entreprise ASB group l'association du
foyer Saint-François deux équipes parmi
les 70 autres engagés dans la course de
caisse à savon oublé de mettre un petit
coup de chiffon sur le sur le le
dégripant que tu mets pour ça tombe pas
sur les freins éviter les failles
techniques c'est le quotidien de cette
entreprise spécialisée dans les piles
thermiques depuis 2 mois la moitié des
90 salariés se relaent autour du bolide
sans que la mécanique ne s'en rille pour
l'esprit d'équipe pour pouvoir côtoyer
ses collègues dans d'autres dans
d'autres conditions que le cadre des
projets ASB voilà pouvoir découvrir
d'autres domaines d'autres activités des
personnes avec lesquelles on travaille
pas d'habitude voilà un moment convivial
mais pour l'entreprise cette course
c'est aussi une promotion au niveau
local on travaille beaucoup à l'in
naational 60 % de notre marché est à
l'export et bon par contre on n'est pas
très connu même pas du tout connu je à
bourge et dès qu'on a je dirais un
recrutement à faire c'est extrêmement
difficile pour nous de trouver des
bonnes compétences dans la la région au
foyer Saint-François même acharnement à
la tâche leur futur véhicule est fait de
matériaux recyclés récupéré ici et là
par les résidents et le personnel
encadrant penser tout ce projet pour des
jeunes au parcours souvent difficile ça
n'est pas rien c'était le fait de leur
faire comprendre qu'on pouvait mener à
bien un projet de A à Z et ce qu' font
aujourd'hui la preuve en est encore là
on le voit en ce moment donc ça c'était
bien c'est de leur faire voir que ils
sont capables au départ on avait des
roues quarti
mais par rapport à la à la
réglementation qu'ils avaient prévu
c'était trop bas donc il a fallu
modifier le système de frein c'était pas
bon on avait des freins à tambour pour
adapter des roues de brouett dessus
c'était pas la joie en attendant que les
bolides soient au point un petit
avantgoût rendez-vous le 27 juin pour la
version grandeur nature de la course